في ايران لا تنحصر تداعيات الانتفاضه التي
اشعلها مقتل هسا ميني في شوارع والساحات
وحتى شرفات المنازل بل طالت العالم
الافتراضي الحكميه
تقرير صادر عن موقع متخصص في الشؤون
الايرانيه اشار الى ان المواقع الحكوميه
الايرانيه شهدت خلال الاشهر الماضيه هجمات
سيبرانيه مختلفه في شكلها ومضمونها من
مخترقين ايرانيين يؤمنون بدورهم في حمايه
المتظاهرين المحتجين على وفاهها امين
هجمات سيبرانيه اريد بها بشكل اساسي
استهداف البنيه الالكترونيه للحكومه
الايرانيه
والتسبب باكبر قدر ممكن من الاضرار لتلك
المواقع ومن ابرز مجموعات القرصنه تلك
وعداله علي وباك دور وبلاكري ورد
التقرير اوضح ايضا ان الهجمات تسببت
بخسائر اقتصاديه وعملياتيه منها ما نتج عن
هجوم فيروس ستوكسنت الذي طال البرنامج
النووي الايراني اضافه الى استهداف منظومه
توزيع الوقود والبنزي التي ادت الى خسائر
ماديه كبيره
وتعطل موقع بلديه طهران الذي يضم مئات
الخدمات والاف عمليات الدفع
كالمقابل تقول سلطات الايرانيه انها تعمل
على تطوير قدرتها الالكترونيه بشكل سريع
من خلال انشاء قاعده دفاعيه مدنيه تراقب
التهديدات وتوفر المعدات وتدعم البنيه
التحتيه والبرمجيات على مدار الساعه وفقا
لنوع التهديدات في محاوله منها لمواجهه
تلك الهجمات الالكترونيه التي تصاعدت في
الاونه الاخيره في وقت تؤكد فيه المؤشرات
على ان العالم الافتراضي سيكون ميدان حروب
المستقبل
رند الشيخ العربي
[موسيقى]